- [Gary] Anything,
anything I could help with,
or answer any questions,
anything of that nature?
- [Audience Member] I'm curious to know
about your social media presence in China.
- Okay.
- Because I recently, I was listening
to one of your talks, and you say
that Weibo is actually the
fastest-growing channel--
- Mhm, mhm.
- [Audience Member] at the moment.
Yeah, so just, your experience--
- Yeah, of course, so I'm--
I have a presence on Weibo and WeChat,
and, let me see if I can pull it up--
And, I'm also
doing quite a bit
with a Facebook Chinese page
that is actually growing
ridiculously well.
And so, in general...
In general,
to me,
I think about this in, kind
of, 30- or 40-year windows,
and the thought of not having
presence in mainland China
is almost like not existing
in that, kind of, window.
And so, I'm doing KOL collaborations
with people who are trying to
build a presence in the U.S.
or the rest of the world,
and obviously, two core
things I speak a lot about,
entrepreneurship and, I'd
call it family dynamics
of psychology of what 20-
to 30-year olds go through,
are clearly over indexing subject matter
for a lot of mainland Chinese
youthful entrepreneurs,
and so, it's really, really
growing very rapidly.
- I was listening to
your YouTube video about
how in your twenties, you
should really just explore
and not to be to risk-averse,
and, obviously,
I've grown up in Finland,
and I've received
a very sort of traditional Chinese--
well, not education, but
the way that I was brought up.
- Point of view.
- [Audience Member] So,
I mean, that's something
I don't think that,
in mainland China, anyone's
ever said to those kids
that, you know--
- I don't think they've
said it in the U.S. either.
Or Europe, for that matter.
And it's interesting, right?
Like, I think...
I think about it in two ways,
I think there's two ways
to win your twenties.
I think you either go all in and, like,
work your face off and
build that foundation,
or you go completely
in the other direction,
and you go higher risk, higher reward,
to try to just to figure yourself out,
and taste a lot of different things,
yeah, I mean, you know, it--
It actually isn't logical or practical
the way that we're all brought up
and like, how we're supposed
to address 22 to 30.
It's supposed to be,
like, okay, go attack it,
settle it down and build a foundation.
It just doesn't--
It, it had a lot more merit
when people lived to 50 years old.
It just doesn't have as much merit
in the way the world is today,
the opportunities that are gifted.
Yeah, I mean, a lot of
the things I think about
challenge conventional wisdom,
because what I think I tend to do is
layer the reality of the current world
and not just think what used to work
in a pre-Internet Industrial Revolution,
you know, 1960s-70s-80s world.
- [Audience Member] I'm
thinking about tapes for us,
we have to be renewing
ourselves everyday on social,
and, ask every other company, too...
Yeah, but we're doing campaigns,
we're doing inspirational content,
so what are the takes like,
from your perspective,
and, how do you see, like,
commercial campaigns on social?
- So a thing that I think
will make sense to you guys
is that, I think that a
company like [redacted]--
I did a little homework for this meeting,
I think they get fragmented too much,
meaning, in social, it
is either things like
Dane & Dale content to fill the pipes,
which is aspirational and nice, and maybe
spending too much time
worrying about engagement
and not enough time about
what the business results are.
Then, they spend a lot of money
on outdoor and television
and traditional branding--
To me, the biggest
opportunity in social is
doing brand work inside of Facebook.
To me, the number one thing I would do
if I took over marketing for [redacted],
is I would produce 50-second
to four-minute videos
for Facebook with the
intent of brand and sales.
- That long videos?
- Long videos.
- Really?
- Mhm.
- [Audience Member] What
is the reason for that?
- Because they work.
- [Audience Member] We have seen that
shorter videos seem to work--
- Shorter videos work for
the vanity metrics of social media,
and the way you judge
shareability or consumption.
But when you look at actual
attribution to a transaction
or the ability to--
Let's play it out.
Okay, so you make a
20-second video on Facebook,
let's say it gets 100,000 engaged.
Liked, shared, commented.
And then you run a 2:19 video
that has a lot more breath
to, like, what you're about.
That one may have 17,000 people watch it;
it may cost you more money on media to get
17,000 engaged than 100,000.
But, when you go to re-target those 17,000
versus the 100,000,
the math tends to work out
on the smaller, deeper group
than the wider, shorter group.
And so, I think that, being in [Redacted],
unlike being a bottled water company,
is when they go to re-target,
there's still a retailer and
they can't see all the math.
For you, when you re-target,
it's black and white.
You'll be able to see the CAC and the LTV
on the transaction that
you're looking for.
So I think the biggest mistake
a lot of the big companies make
is they do social media for
the sake of social media,
not for the sake of the actual
business skills they have.
And they don't hold
traditional dollars they spend
to the level of accountability
that they do in the new world,
because the new world
has so much more metrics.
You have no idea if there's
three-second or ten-second
viewability on your commercials,
you don't know the
impressions of your outdoor,
you've "accepted" it because
it's always been done,
but you hold the new stuff
to a level of scrutiny
that you don't with the old stuff.
- Yeah.
- So, to me, that's where
the big miss is, for...
- [Audience Member] How do
you see, like, very technical,
advertisement in social media.
Should those be done or
should it be just for brand--
- I think both work. I think
branding and selling work.
There's enormous amounts of
selling to be done on Facebook;
I think you can't be half-pregnant.
I think a lot of people try
to hide sales into
branding, and vise-versa,
I think there's a lack
of a good conversation
between the difference
between a piece of content
that's meant for branding and
one that's meant for sales,
and I think most organizations over index,
in respecting one or the other.
You have some companies
that don't like social media
because all they want to
do is be DR marketers,
and that's why they favor Google,
and then you have other people
who don't value social media
because all they want to do is brand work,
and they think television or sponsorships
are "better brand work."
And that's why social,
and specifically Facebook,
has this incredible opportunity right now,
'cause its underpriced attention,
because not enough money's going into it
either from DR or brand.
Yet, if you look at Wish,
if you look at so many other companies,
they do their marketing
and their selling--
Purple Mattress, many
other companies, Lola,
in that environment--
That's why I'm so bullish on it.
The issue is, like anything,
the ROI of these two markers
is completely predicated
on my talent to draw
with these two markers.
And I think that there's a sophistication,
both mathematically and artistically
and strategically and psychologically
that it takes to be good at
any marketing in any medium,
and I think most people
are applying old principles
into this new environment,
which is why they're
not getting the results.
To your point, this bottled
water company would rather
put something like, you know,
a #WednesdayWisdom post because
they're gonna get 87 likes
on, you know, the post
without really understanding
if that's going to lead to selling, here.
I think there's a lack of thoughtfulness
in most people's--
you know--
overall marketing
strategy, digital strategy,
and then social strategy.
- [Audience Member] When you
were looking our Facebook site,
what did you think?
What were our--
- What I couldn't tell--
What I was looking for, more, was
how much marketing you
were doing actually,
in the traditional world.
When I was looking at Facebook,
the biggest thing I don't know is
are you running Facebook
ads that I don't see
on your feed? You know...z
- Which I would hope you
are, and more importantly,
is far more important
than what I would see.
I was less analyzing your social,
I was more trying to get a sense of
how much traditional media you were doing
in the name of branding.
Because, as I've just said earlier,
the number one thing I
would do if I were you
is much more branding inside of Facebook.
That, to me is, you know, I would argue,
the unique point of view
by comparison to most right now,
that I think has the most upside.
- [Audience Member] What
do you think about bots
and artificial intelligence,
now that it's like--
and we know that many of us at [Redacted]
have been taking those
bots very seriously,
they have been doing good
work inside Messenger
and so on...
We aren't there yet,
we have a bot qualification--
- You need to get there.
- It's taking baby steps.
- You need to get--
You are gonna get caught
if you fall behind too much
because all of your customer service
is gonna happen through that environment.
You're gonna save a fortune.
- Yeah?
- It's gonna be better, more efficient,
higher conversion, and lower cost.
You need to be serious about Messenger,
and I think, when you
look at mainland China,
the U.S., VK in Russia,
the AI message bot infrastructure
is going to be very important.
Consumers will interact with those bots
because they're gonna get--
it's time saving.
- [Audience Member] Yeah, that is true.
- It's gonna take time...
It's gonna take two or three years
for it to be the behavior that I think
a lot of technologists are looking for,
but, I mean, I'm a very big fan of it.
It will be there.
- [Audience Member] How
do you see, like, social,
should it be in-house
or should it be, out--
- I think everything should be in-house.
Which is funny, considering
what I do for a living.
I think, what I've learned is
that most companies aren't--
the reason they don't do
in-house is two reasons--
One, strictly from a Wall Street-
or publicly-traded company standpoint,
they don't want the expenses on their PnL,
which hurts them in public markets,
or two, they just don't retain the talent,
and they feel like we're--
you know, they lose that continuity.
To me, anything you can do in-house
is always going to be interesting
unless they're somebody
who's hungry enough...
The way I would run--
if I owned a company, the
way I would play agencies
is I would work with independent shops
who are on their way to try
to sell to holding companies,
'cause they're gonna care more,
they're just different.
So, I think the biggest
issues with agencies
and with brands is agencies
are publicly-held companies,
you know, so much consolidation, that--
- Yeah, and they don't
love our brand like...
We, kind of see in that window--
- I think that's right.
But I also think what agencies do do well,
including others is, they're
able to see your brand
in a different way than you are.
- [Audience Member] Yeah?
- Everybody thinks their
kids are the prettiest,
so I think that's where
they can bring sensibility.
My biggest problem with agencies is
they don't produce enough work
for the cost associated.
I think that's where we're
really kind of winning,
is we're--
First of all, I built the
agency mainly to buy brands.
So, I have far more ambition
to become my clients
than to be an agency,
which aligns our interests better
and what we realized after
we got great at media was,
oh my God we have to
produce so much content
to take advantage of the media landscape,
so we built our own 50,000
square foot production facility,
and had a much deeper religion
on the cost of creative
that I think the market
has been accustomed to,
without giving up this
magical idea of quality.
You know, when I first
got into the business,
I came from startup land
and entrepreneur land
and Silicon Valley,
and I would look at a video,
you know a commercial,
and I literally was like,
"How the hell does this cost $600,000?"
You know, I just couldn't get there.
So I think, our great ambition--
Back to the--
So our motto is,
if you're a brand that does a commercial
and it costs $800,000 in out-of-pocket
and creative and production,
we try to convince that client to do
six or five or four or three
long-form Facebook videos
for that same cost,
which can, first, fit
different demographics, right?
Because when you do one
commercial, it's just vanilla,
whereas, you know,
if you star an Asian, you
know, family in their twenties
and target Asian Americans or
Europeans in their twenties,
you're gonna over index in relevance,
and then we also think the
media costs of distribution
are more efficient,
because, I think the biggest conversation
that you also probably want
to have on the media front,
is there's potential reach
and then there's actual reach.
And I think the market trades a potential
and doesn't layer common sense.
I mean, there's almost no
market left in the world
that OTT hasn't eaten up
such a substantial percentage
of television content consumption,
that it's made every commercial
reared grossly overpriced.
- [Audience Member] At
least hearing [Redacted]
influence your landscape,
we're seeing the same faces everywhere
- Well it's a small market.
- [Audience Member] Endorsing the--
- Yeah, over and over.
- [Audience Member] Everything.
- Yeah, I think, to your point,
one thing I did look at, and,
I had a meetup last night
with four of the ten faces...
Yeah, I think there's a
lot to be left desired
in influencer marketing.
But I think that's where
you probably want to look at
the global nature of your business,
and look at the pockets
where you can play--
Or, using those same
faces in other markets.
So I do think they're inexpensive.
So I do think, what's
interesting about your ten faces,
is in a U.S.-centric
campaign, with that, kind of,
level of YouTube, which is really
what we're seeing [Redacted] following,
there probably is an inexpensive way
to do some very clever collaborations
where you might be able
to take those four to ten,
do some sort of collab with
two or three U.S.-centric--
in the U.S., there's
something that I think
would really work for you, which is
family vlogging is very big,
and some of it can get pretty affluent.
And I could see a lot of
interesting collabs of, like,
that family going to [Redacted].
There's something to be done
that I think you could hack.
So I think, if you're
thinking for this market,
your domestic market, I would say
how underpriced Facebook
and Instagram ads are,
is probably the strategy I would deploy.
If I thought about the influencer market,
I would use them as
ambassadors on the outside,
because what's great
about YouTube is this,
let me play it out for you.
You take a YouTuber with
600,000 subscribers,
he's still cheap.
Like you could probably
give a couple [Redacted],
or, fine, a little bit of bucks,
but in the ecosystem of YouTube,
if there's people with a
million subscribers in the U.S.,
the idea to do a collaboration
with him is exciting
'cause they wanna siphon fans from him.
So he's more valuable
as an asset out there,
you see where I'm going?
And this is what I was talking
about with thoughtfulness,
I think the level of sophistication and
the way people fragment all
these different things--
and that's why, I think, we've invested
so much in strategy--
our biggest growth has been--
so we used to meet somebody like you,
and if we wanted to do business,
we're like, okay, you can
give us your media budget,
you can give us your creative budget,
and I think the thing that we've realized
in the last couple of years is,
or for €150,000 strategy thing,
we can save clients millions of dollars
with their creative and media partners,
and it's a good way to
get the value out of us.
So, I think even how we're talking now,
that would have been how we probably
would have analyzed your
influencer strategy,
go use their following
count to do collaborations
in other markets with bigger influencers
who are trying to siphon
and use them as a gateway,
as an ambassador to your brand
through that collaboration.
To me, it's unemotional
assets versus costs.
Right?
So, for me, I'm not in love
with Facebook or Instagram,
I'm in love with the price of their ads.
(upbeat music)